[Música]
les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de France 24 empezamos Este
programa en la ciudad francesa de hongo
lema que celebrar los 15 años de su
festival de cine francófono desde 2008
el evento presenta un avance de las
películas en francés que darán que
hablar en las próximas semanas y meses y
este año tiene una amplia y variada
programación de 50 películas incluyendo
10 en competición en las que se mezclan
el cine de autor y el clima pero lo que
se destaca es el homenaje que el
festival rinde a Ruanda tras el
genocidio de los tutsi en el que
murieron entre 800 mil y un millón de
personas en la primavera de 1994 el cine
fue un modo de expresión artística
privilegiado para poner imágenes a los
males de la tragedia y curar las heridas
y es esta producción múltiple y poco
conocida la que el público puede
descubrir o redescubrir hasta el 28 de
agosto una se de 10 largometrajes y 5
cortometrajes incluida la adaptación
cinematográfica de la exitosa novela
pequeño país de Gael Fire
[Música]
la llegada
en las buenas noticias de la semana un
cuadro icónico se expone por primera vez
en un cuarto de siglo llegó y yo de la
mexicana Frida Kahlo este autorretrato
de Frida Kahlo es hasta la fecha el
cuadro latinoamericano más caro de la
historia fue adquirido del año pasado
porque así 35 millones de dólares y es
ahora el atractivo principal de la
exposición tercer ojo en el Museo de
Arte latinoamericano de Buenos Aires en
malva porque es su fundador Eduardo
constantini quien adquirió la pintura
una obra que reflejada la tormentosa
relación entre Frida Kahlo y su marido
Diego Rivera en este programa no solo el
arte convencional tiene su espacio
queremos también presentarles obras
originales como estas reproducciones de
platos de comida de plástico en Japón
los creadores de estos objetos
hiperrealistas Generalmente utilizados
en los restaurantes como decoración han
dado rienda suelta a su funciona una
torre inclinada de pizzas chorreando
queso fundido un juego de Tetris hecho
con pollo o una gamba frita a cuatro
patas sentadas sobre rayadas son algunas
de las 60 creaciones que se exponen
desde esta semana en un centro comercial
de Tokio
y al revés en Nueva York un museo ofrece
una experiencia única con obras
solamente hechas en dulces y caramelos
la exposición candytopia abrió sus
puertas de nuevo en abrir y sigue
atrayendo a un público que suena con el
mundo de Willy Wonka hecho realidad
nuestra corresponsal mamen sala recorrió
esta singular galería de arte muy
divertido algo diferente
es un buen lugar para ir con la familia
sobre todo si hay niños y si te gusta
Dulce
[Música]
queremos que ellos toquen el arte y
traten de adivinar Qué tipo de compites
usamos para crearlo eso es uno de los
pocos museos que sí dejamos que toquen
las esculturas vamos a hablar ahora de
música con un dúo de artistas que logró
hacer bailar al público de la feria de
las flores en Medellín y del festival de
música del Pacífico petronio Álvarez en
Cali dauer y damper estos hermanos
colombianos están llevando poco a poco
de la profuturismo fuera de sus
fronteras gracias a una propuesta que no
solo es Sonora sino también estética
jugando con los códigos de la moda y de
los videoclips Manuela Cano les preguntó
lo que quieren transmitir con este
trabajo sobre la estética
desde que lo creamos creamos romper un
poco con la con la idea de crear música
urbana y cómo se ve la música urbana
entonces creo que eso es lo que estamos
haciendo como que rompiendo un poco eso
y bueno como que yendo al origen
Nosotros siempre nos ha gustado la moda
siempre me ha gustado el styling
entonces hicimos agregarle eso a nuestro
proyecto total y creo que también el
tema de la estética es otra otra opción
o no otra posibilidad también de hacer
críticas Otra forma de decir cosas a
veces en las canciones o no le alcanza
para contar una historia pero a través
de la audiovisuales las fotografías de
la moda uno puede seguir contando cosas
es como que dejar que la estética y la
moda hable de temas sociales también es
súper importante del lado de las
novedades de la semana viva las dungeons
El séptimo disco de la Banda pop Rock
emo de Estados Unidos de disco se
estrenó antes de lanzarse en una Gira
Mundial de 40 fichas el mes que viene
con paradas en Europa rei y Norteamérica
[Música]
y en el tema mujerón la española
petaceta y La puertorriqueña Villano
antillano fusionaron trap y reggaeton
con una letra empoderada para su primera
colaboración
[Música]
Nos despedimos con el tema banda de Los
dos nigerianos
de homenaje a las víctimas de las
fuerzas policiales la brigada especial
antirrobo de Nigeria Gracias a ustedes
por suscribirse y cuídense Chuchuwa
[Música]